y
[Música]
en esta emisión de noticias de france 24
diego armando maradona considerado por
la fifa como el jugador de fútbol del
siglo y uno de los más destacados
exponentes de ese deporte a nivel
mundial falleció a sus 60 años debido a
un paro cardiorrespiratorio argentina y
el mundo del deporte lloran su partida
la noticia de la muerte del futbolista
argentino diego armando maradona
rápidamente le dio la vuelta al mundo
desde jefes de estado y de gobierno
deportistas artistas líderes de opinión
y también personalidades han lamentado
su fallecimiento tenemos algunas de las
reacciones a nivel internacional
y miles de mujeres se tomaron las calles
de varias capitales en américa latina'
para conmemorar el día internacional de
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres solo en américa latina' más
de 4.600 de ellas fueron asesinadas en
el año 2019 una de cada tres mujeres en
el mundo ha padecido algún tipo de
violencia en su vida
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos hasta
ahora el mundo entero le dice adiós al
astro del fútbol argentino diego armando
maradona quien falleció a los 60 años en
su casa en el norte de buenos aires en
donde se recuperaba después de haber
sido sometido a una cirugía por un edema
craneal el pasado 11 de noviembre
todavía estamos a la espera de un
resultado concluyente de la autopsia
oficial pero los primeros indicios
médicos apuntan a que maradona falleció
debido a un paro cardiorrespiratorio
desde el gobierno argentino decretaron
tres días de duelo nacional y su cuerpo
será velado en la casa rosada la sede
del gobierno federal argentino vamos a
conocer más detalles de esta noticia que
enluta al mundo del deporte
previamente conversamos con él guillermo
crol él es periodista escritor y también
analista deportivo y le preguntamos el
significado de la muerte de diego
armando maradona para el fútbol
argentino esto fue lo que nos dijo
buenas noches si realmente se extiende
un capítulo de una historia de amor
entre diego maradona y las pelotas y
sobre todo con los argentinos a quienes
vivo montones de satisfacciones
justamente después de una dictadura
sangrienta después de una guerra y
infame y poder instalar un mundial en el
año 86 y sobre todo poder ganarle a
inglaterra en un partido clave
de hecho de hecho este importante crisis
era diego maradona que nos hizo olvidar
de horror abrir su 16o no algo increíble
pensado
pues en rápidamente la muerte del
futbolista argentino comenzó a ser
comentada en diferentes redes sociales
también en diferentes medios de
comunicación por parte de personalidades
internacionales de todo tipo jefes de
gobierno jefes de estado deportistas
artistas líderes de opinión todos ellos
expresaron sus condolencias al pueblo
argentino al fútbol internacional y
sobre todo a la familia de diego
maradona
nuestro compañero luís muñoz hace un
repaso por algunas de estas reacciones
internacionales de ambos
el de hoy es uno de esos días en los que
es difícil no hablar maradona causaba
filias y fobias una trascendencia
histórica a la que se han rendido los
más grandes si hay un enemigo íntimo ese
ha sido el brasileño pelé el debate
público siempre ha mantenido una eterna
disputa entre cuál es el mejor jugador
de todos los tiempos la leyenda
brasileña aprovechó su cuenta de
'twitter' para lamentar la pérdida del
'pelusa' y afirmó que triste noticia
perdí a un gran amigo y el mundo perdió
a una gran leyenda en esa discusión sólo
un jugador después de ellos ha podido
mostrar que puede estar por encima es
leo messi y aunque las comparaciones son
odiosas
ambos han vestido la camiseta azulgrana
del fc barcelona y la albiceleste de la
selección argentina en un comunicado en
instagram messi dejó un emotivo nos deja
pero no se va porque el diego es eterno
si hay un lugar en el mundo más allá de
argentina donde maradona será imposible
de olvidar es nápoles en italia allí
consiguió sus grandes triunfos como
futbolista de club y así lo demuestran
las concentraciones que los tifosi
napolitanos han realizado desde el
momento de su muerte el club italiano en
twitter ha puesto un escueto y sentido
para siempre adiós diego con una imagen
que muestra la felicidad de aquellos
años pero más allá del fútbol
el mito trasciende y en argentina se
declararon tres días de luto oficial y
su cuerpo será velado en la casa rosada
así habló el presidente de argentina
alberto fernández en su cuenta de
twitter en la que se rindió a la figura
argentina con un gracias por haber
existido diego te vamos a extrañar toda
la vida fútbol política e icono popular
son múltiples las referencias en el
mundo de la cultura a su figura pero sí
que destacar una esa es la canción de
andrés calamaro que dice aquello de
maradona no es una persona cualquiera el
cantante argentino también quiso
dedicarle un homenaje con las palabras
espérame en el cielo querido hermano
estas son sólo algunas de una larga
lista de las reacciones por la muerte de
maradona un mito que durará para siempre
y cambiamos de tema américa latina se
convirtió en foco de las marchas
conmemorativas del día internacional de
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres
precisamente esta región es una en donde
se presentan la mayor cantidad de casos
de violencia una de cada tres mujeres ha
padecido violencia a lo largo de su vida
mientras que durante el 2019 los
feminicidios superaron los 4600 según lo
indica el observatorio de igualdad de
género de américa latina y del caribe
una cifra que por supuesto podría
empeorar en 2020 ya que la violencia
aumentó durante la cuarentena por el cob
y 19 miles de manifestantes
tanto en las principales capitales como
en otras ciudades se han salido para
movilizarse allí y mostrar su rechazo a
la discriminación de género exigir leyes
contra los crímenes machistas y también
mostrar su respaldo a la despenalización
de la interrupción del embarazo incluso
las medidas contra la pandemia no
impidieron que miles de ciudadanos
salieran a las calles para exigir sus
demandas y para reivindicar la igualdad
de la mujer marina sardiña de la
redacción de france 24 recorrió las
calles del centro de bogotá la capital
de colombia y nos da más detalles de
esta jornada y del panorama en este país
en el siguiente reporte
este 25 de noviembre miles de mujeres
han salido a las calles de colombia para
conmemorar el día internacional de la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer que este año tiene una coyuntura
especial debido a la pandemia que
agravado los derechos de las mujeres
dejando cifras alarmantes en colombia al
menos 243 mujeres fueron víctimas de
feminicidios durante los meses de
cuarentena pero además las cuarentenas y
el aislamiento lleva con muchas mujeres
estuvieran encerradas con sus agresores
lo que provoca un aumento en las
llamadas a las líneas de atención del
ciento 63 por ciento sólo en el primer
mes de confinamiento por ello muchas
mujeres de colombia y distintas
agrupaciones feministas han organizado
una multitudinaria marcha en la que se
han llevado a cabo diferentes actos
reivindicativos actuaciones musicales
intervenciones artísticas también
pañuelazos frente a la corte para
reivindicar el derecho al aborto de las
mujeres en colombia y una marcha a la
que ha participado mujeres de todas las
edades en las que están reivindicando el
derecho de las mujeres al de a una vida
sin violencias
eso en cuanto a colombia pero si hay un
país que padece la violencia de género y
los feminicidios es méxico allí también
miles de mujeres salieron a las calles
para rechazar la violencia machista
-mario carbón el corresponsal de france
24 en ciudad de méxico estuvo en una de
estas marchas en la capital mexicana y
nos cuenta en detalle en el siguiente
reporte
en este 25 de noviembre las mujeres en
la ciudad de mexico salen a las calles
consideran que el virus de la violencia
contra las mujeres es igual o más
peligroso que el virus del cob y aquí
está araceli osorio quien se ha
convertido en un emblema de la lucha
contra el feminicidio tras el
feminicidio de su hija cómo estás
araceli que te atraparán
pues no
lo que nos hace salir a las calles sigue
siendo darles voz y presencia a las que
ya no están a las que nos han arrebatado
de las maneras más crueles a las que no
nos se murieron nos asesinaron darles
voz a las mujeres que de momento no se
encuentran en sus hogares porque a
alguien se la llevó no desaparecieron a
alguien se las llevó y tenemos que
encontrarnos para que nos digan qué fue
lo que pasó quién se las llevó y por qué
todo esto salimos a las calles porque en
méxico a pesar de que ha llegado otro
gobierno nos siguen asesinando a las
mujeres nos siguen desapareciendo siguen
ejerciendo violencia sobre nuestros
cuerpos y ahora más
por niñas y mujeres
así es en un país donde entre enero y
octubre hay más de 800 feminicidios 8 de
cada 10 mujeres tienen miedo de salir a
la calle por temor a ser agredidas y
seis de cada diez mujeres han sufrido
algún tipo de violencia por eso
protestan las mujeres en méjico en este
vídeo
[Música]
y con este reporte desde la capital
mexicana llegamos al final de las
noticias en france 24 más información
usted las puede tener también en la
página web france24 puntocom también en
las redes sociales y por supuesto en la
app descargando la en sus dispositivos
móviles siga con nuestra programación
buenas noches
[Música]